[Music]
yeah I do still have the flat cap I'm
wearing it today cuz I shoveled the
driveway earlier and my hair got all
sweaty and gross and I did not feel like
prettying myself up for this video so
James Summerton if you don't know who he
is or what's going on with him that will
not be the purpose of this video this is
not a drama video this is not a recap
this is not me going through all the
things that have gone on with him if you
don't know who James Summerton is and
you don't know why so many people are
talking about him right now I'm going to
recommend two videos one from H bomber
guy one from Todd and the Shadows the
first one deals with plagiarism the
second one deals with lies so if you
want to know why a seemingly previously
well respected video essayist is now
just on the tip of everybody's tongu for
the worst reasons watch those two videos
and come on back I'll see you in about 7
hours more realistically I'll see you
tomorrow but regardless I'm not going
over all that I'm not going over what
he's doing not doing there are other
people who can and will do that I want
to talk about what lessons can be taken
from all of this and over the course of
this I'll make reference to some of the
stuff he did but as I said that's not
the focus I'm not going to go over that
any of it part of the reason why I'm
doing this video is because when I talk
about these things in general I like to
do it from a perspective that I feel
might actually add something to the
conversation and I'm not saying nobody
is talking about what lessons to take
from this but that's usually part of a
much bigger discussion about all of it
and I just want to narrow in on that I'm
also kind of hoping that if I do a video
with my overall thoughts on this which
the takeaways are really all I have to
say other than pointing you to the two
videos I already pointed you to then
maybe this conversation won't dominate
you know my
streams people won't have to ask me
it'll be right here maybe that'll happen
maybe it won't we'll see the last thing
I'll say before I get into this is I
have really no personal stake in James
Summerton not only do I not know him
personally I didn't even really know his
work I'd heard his name intermittently
sometimes very rarely it would come up
in my own comment section usually in a
positive light and on a couple of
occasions his name came out of people
who I know and trust and do some work to
what I do and often times then it was
not said with uh as positive a
connotation but I never watched any of
his videos they choke him my
recommendations now and then but usually
he was either taking a look at a topic
that I might have interest in but coming
at it from an angle that wasn't my
interest in the thing or it just looks
so heavy that I'm like I don't have the
spoons for that which happens sometimes
there you should see my watch later
playlist it's ridiculous there's tons of
stuff in there that I'm sure was great
some of it even made by friends of mine
but I'm like I don't know spoons for
that right now I'll get back to it when
I do and he seemed to cover a lot of
stuff like that but I am not personally
offended I have never watched his stuff
I never supported him I really don't
know much more than what I've been
hearing about him as a person or even
his work but because those two videos
that I mentioned earlier have so many
receipts and are so very thorough in
their citations of where they're getting
their information from and being very
upfront about where the about where
their conclusions are more solid or more
shaky again those are the places to go
for that I do have good faith that those
videos are well supported and well
backed up again you can watch them
yourself but I feel like there's two
main sets of lessons to be taken from
this there's lessons to take as viewers
and then there's lessons to take as
creators we're going to start with
viewers first because well more of my
audience audience are just viewers and
not also other creators and the back
half is going to be a little bit more
Naval gazy so uh I figure I'll give
people the option to duck out if they're
not interested in the back half yeah
see I'm willing to hurt my own metrics
if I was smart I'd save the stuff that
applies to more people for the back half
and force people to watch more of the
video apparently I'm more considera of
your time than I am of my own
engagement this is why I haven't broken
100,000 subscribers yet ah well this is
just me so I think the main thing that
seems like the obvious thing but it's
really a lesson that we apparently have
to keep
relearning confirmation bias I mean most
of us know that term the general idea
that you read or hear or see something
that agrees with a general sometimes a
specific but just a belief that you have
and because it matches something you
already believe you don't inter
interogate it and you don't question it
with the same scrutiny as you would
something that is saying something that
you don't agree with the thing is
whenever I see people talking about
confirmation bias they're usually
talking about well cranks to be honest
they point at people like Alex Jones and
say that confirmation bias and
conspiratorial thinking is the only
reason anyone would believe or listen to
someone like him and yes that is a
factor but confirmation bias can blind
us to somebody who looks like they know
what they're talking talking about the
appeal of somebody like Alex Jones to
someone who already leans that way of
thinking is finally somebody saying the
things that I know to be true and that
can be there and that can get people
into more Extreme Ways of thought but it
can also just cause us to not examine
something because we think yeah that
sounds about right and if it's presented
in a far more professional fashion we're
going to be a lot less likely to
question whether or not we've got
confirmation bias on it which kind of
brings in the second thing I think we
forget sometimes how much professional
appearance and confident
presentation can trick us into just
accepting somebody's Authority we accept
and believe and trust that they know
what they're talking about because the
way that they present themselves really
seems like they did their research and
it also helps that in the case well I
say helps hurts hurts us helps him in
the case of someone like James Summerton
he claims to have done research and when
somebody claims that they've done
research especially if we're already
inclined to agree with the types of
conclusions that he's coming to well
we're usually going to take his word on
that if only because to not take his
word on that means to do our own
research and fact check everything that
he said and again we're far more likely
to do that with someone we don't agree
with than with someone we do we'll just
go oh well he said that he researched it
so yeah I'll I'll Trust his summations
and like he's citing sources so you know
he wouldn't do that if if if they didn't
agree with what he was saying there are
problems with that assumption too but
again check out the other videos for
that he didn't cite often and when he
did it was poorly but just the
appearance of citations can give a sense
of authority to something again that
presentation presenting something in a
confident tone of voice
with that sense of authority with that
tone of I've looked into this and so
I've come to the conclusion for you you
don't have to think you just have to
listen I think the left has gotten very
good at noticing the you don't have to
think I've already done it for you
technique that the right uses very
frequently this is core to things like
the daily wi and a lot of the outrage
merchants on here but the left can do it
too not necessarily for the same
political ends although also yeah
sometimes but just for financial
gain because we have a tendency to just
assume that somebody who says they
looked into it actually did and until we
find reason to disbelieve them we tend
to just default to that there's a bit
from the novel version of good Omens
that I always loved and bugged me a
little bit that they didn't put it into
the first season but I love this idea
because there's some people trying to
break into what is effectively a nuclear
facility and it's basically pointed out
that like getting in is the hard part
once you're in as long as you act like
you're supposed to be there people just
assume you are because well if you're
here okay I guess you're supposed to be
here so unless you act super suspicious
they're not going to question it this is
kind of the academic video essay
equivalent of the same thing well you're
here you're presenting it in a way that
seems that seems good passes the sniff
test to most people yeah yeah you must
be
right again a lot of it comes down to
this is a harsher word than I mean it
but laziness and I don't mean that
audiences are lazy and they should have
checked everything he said no if you
wanted to do that you would literally be
doing your own research and probably be
making better video essays than people
like James Summerton do but if you're an
audience you're here to get somebody
else's summation and
conclusions and even if you sometimes
question I'm not sure about that we tend
to still accept that somebody did the
base level work based off of certain
amount of confirmation bias a certain
amount of it's just presented so well
but also we have to tackle the fact that
James is gay that's the lens that he
generally puts on it and
as much as there are certain aspects of
the left and the queer community in
specific that can have infighting and
eat at each other by and large that also
can lead to a reluctance to call each
other
out cuz here's the
thing trying to call out James sumon
prior to the videos that I linked before
and I'll come back and circle on why I
think these ones have broken through it
was frankly kind of hazardous because
you risk not only the standard thing of
calling out any sizable YouTuber which
is his fans would come and defend him
and possibly attack you over it but in
addition to that even people who might
not necessarily consider themselves fans
of him are possibly going to jump to his
defense simply because we see so much of
queer creators just being torn down
because they're queer but under the
guise of of so many other
things we're a bit hyp sensitive to it h
bomber guy actually brought that up in
his own video that part of what made him
nervous when he first started looking
into this is yeah there is a lot of
false accusation a lot of nonsense said
about queer creators and you don't want
to contribute to that and as an open
bisexual who knows what the internet is
like I'm Vigilant to the possibility the
phobes are making a fuss about nothing
again to take down a fellow gay boy it
does happen
but on the other hand you don't want to
contribute it but you also don't want to
get accused of contributing to it even
if you're not it's difficult sometimes
to criticize things when the other
people making similar criticisms are
people you don't want to be associated
with it's difficult to be critical of
something for a reason that you feel
very passionate about in the case of
someone like James Summerton that he
lies and steals material and you're
going this this guy's content is
actually bad and people shouldn't be
watching it and then you look over next
to you to see the other people saying
this and a good chunk of them
are people
who uh don't like the queer
Community for bigoted reasons I mean
this has happened to be on a lower scale
God years ago even I had fundamental
issues with the 2016 Ghostbusters movie
Just the idea of it not cuz it women but
because it was a continuity reboot and
that annoyed me but I had to be even
back then quite careful about how I
talked about my criticisms of that
because looking around next to me at who
else was getting annoyed at the very
Prospect of that movie and it was a lot
of
sexists and sometimes you just decide I
don't even want to risk association with
these people I'll just keep my mouth
shut but that's the other thing not
everyone did keep their mouth
shut it should not have taken
these two videos to blow the lid off of
James
Summerton because there are people many
of them from within the queer Community
who have been signaling that there's
something wrong with this guy for a long
time but because of the inherent desire
of both his audience and other content
creators other queer content creators in
specific to want those accusations to
not be
true it generally got ignored and I
don't think like purposefully I don't
think people are like we cannot this is
our precious boy and you cannot have him
I think it's much more a case of unless
somebody came with so much overwhelming
evidence when you're hearing things one
at a time when you're hearing this
incident of plagiarism when you're
hearing this thing that that's not
accurate and you're hearing them in
isolation and until somebody compiles
this stuff which is what H bomber guy
and Todd and the Shadows did it can be
easy to brush off or to compartmentalize
or to think okay well that's just a
thing that happened that
time but other people either didn't have
the time the means or the stomach to
present everything and they shouldn't
have had to there were enough people
often enough
signaling that something's off here it
shouldn't have been necessary for
someone to compile all this stuff into a
cornucopia of evidence that can't be
ignored in its volume even if some of
the specific incidents are stronger than
others as far as the evidence goes but
it did come to that because of a
combination of confirmation bias are
defaulting to a sense of authority like
again to make the comparison to the
right there's a reason that people have
a tendency to gravitate or get pulled in
by folks like Ben Shapiro or Jordan
Peterson Shapiro presents his stuff very
confidently Peterson couches his stuff
in academic language and it brings a
sense of authority and it's easier to
just assume that they're right
especially if you're already kind of at
least leaning in that direction but we
are not immune to the same thing so as
an audience what do we do well like I
said you can't expect an audience to
just fact check everything it would be
nice if audiences would be more willing
to listen when someone who has fact
checked something goes hey wait a minute
but that's sort of addressing fan
culture in general and I don't know how
to fix that here's what I will say for
me the most frustrating thing about
what's happened with
Summerton is how stuff proliferated out
from him especially his lies you know
the plagiarism and him effectively
taking credit for other people's
thoughts already not good but he would
just say nonsense and then people would
cite him when they would repeat it
because they assumed he did research and
they assumed he had something to back
that up but he often didn't so while I'm
not going to say you need to double
check everything a video essay says
because no you shouldn't have to but at
the very least if you're gonna repeat
something that you've only heard from
them get a second source and to make
your life a little easier I personally
at least would consider a second source
to include whatever Source they claimed
they got it from because at the very
least you can go and check and go oh
this is what he brought up and yeah that
says what he said that at the very least
before you spread
it and that is honestly starting to lean
into an issue more with creators cuz
fans you know you absorb stuff you don't
always remember where you get it and you
say it again and fans don't necessarily
have the most responsibility to not
spread it it'd be nice if they took a
little but like again I don't think
that's reasonable just as human beings
but that starts to Pivot us into
creators and what lessons creators can
Lear
and we'll start with um your your source
for anything you're going to repeat
yourself on a podcast or a uh YouTube
video should probably not be other
creators unless they are talking about
their own direct experience or they
conducted their own interviews or
whatnot if they are the primary source
okay if they're not probably best to
check what their primary source was
before you repeat it um
you know just as a general thing if
you're able to of course that requires
proper citations which James didn't
really do so that complicates things but
maybe then question oh there wasn't a
citation for that and I can't find it
maybe I shouldn't repeat it but let's go
fully into what creators can learn from
this and yes I'm going to focus this
pretty much through my own lens and my
thoughts and how I go about creation but
let's see what I'm learning and maybe
that'll help others or you'll at least
find it interesting now when I say these
are the lessons that I'm taking these
are things for me to watch out so that I
don't appear to be anything like James
Summerton now like just the core of what
I do is not what he did and I don't even
just mean like the plagiarism and the
lying I mean I don't really consider
myself to be a video
essayist I just don't I've done a couple
of things that I think could probably
qualify under that but that's not what I
consider myself to be that's not my
primary thing I am more than anything
into media analysis and criticism and
the thing about analysis and criticism
is they are primarily if not entirely
based off My Views and my
opinions and you can't really fact check
an opinion and I can't really back it up
empirically with citations the way that
I go about what I do is pretty much to
tell you my views on a thing and do my
best to explain why I have them but I'm
generally not trying to present
something as this is the absolute
factual truth I'm presenting something
as this is what I'm taking away from
this or this is the lens I'm viewing
this through and again a big part of my
focus is to be sure that people
understand why I have come to the
conclusions or have the perspective that
I have even if they don't agree with me
and since most of what I'm talking about
is here's the lens of analysis I'm
putting on this and that's not
specifically like an academic lens like
this is a Marxist reading of this work
I'm not that academically inclined so I
don't claim to do that kind of thing I
just have the perspective that I
do that having been said sometimes I do
things that are much more about things
that I need to be sure that I get right
now the plagiarism aspect I'm not super
concerned about for my own work getting
going forward mostly because uh if you
didn't realize this I don't script much
the vast majority of what you see on
this channel including what you're
watching right now is technically
unscripted I say technically in so far
as I have notes I have bullet points and
I may or may not have started to sort of
talk this through like I don't know
while making breakfast or taking a
shower shoveling the driveway and I've
started to go over it just to sort of
format maybe the order I want to do
things and figure out what the tangents
my brain is liable to go on and try and
determine in advance is that a tangent
worth hitting but I don't script the
vast majority of what you see so it's
hard for me to plagiarize you can't
really copy and paste somebody else's
words into a script if you don't have a
script now is it possible for me to like
take somebody else's idea and kind of
repackage it yes that's possible I don't
do that intentionally and I don't think
I've really done that in a significantly
notable way even unintentionally but at
the very least by virtue of the fact
that it's unscripted I can't be
presenting it exactly the way that they
did
cuz I didn't write this down that's not
to say that I never script but the times
that I
script they tend to be things where I
either really need to be careful about
how I'm formatting the entire thing like
if I don't do these things in this order
then my conclusion doesn't land
correctly and rambling and just seeing
how it pulls together isn't the way to
address that or it's something with a
lot of specific facts that I need to get
right and if I don't the entire thing is
pointless so some examples of stuff that
I have scripted and scripted really
thoroughly include things like the video
earlier this year that I did on trans
genocide video from last year about the
don't say gay Bill those are two
examples where I scripted it because I
was talking about laws I needed to look
up what the laws actually said and I
would put that information up on the
screen so those were scripted but I
wasn't going to other people's
summations in those specific instances I
was going to the core things I did see
some people's summations like this is
basically what this law means I'm like
can I see the actual thing and sometimes
it would be illegally I couldn't parse
and if that was the case
I probably wouldn't even bring that one
up but if I could feel that I understood
it I was going to primary sources on
that but that's the kind of stuff that I
actually script either that or sometimes
things where I want to be sure I don't
put my foot in my mouth um so an example
there would be uh the video that I did
on disability representation uh and also
the one that I did on fat Thor those are
cases where I'm talking about um
elements and aspects of life and people
and bodies that are not my own personal
experience and aren't things I typically
talk about so those were scripted just
to be sure that I didn't say something
harmful not only were those ones
scripted but I also ran them by friends
of mine who would have very valid
opinions on these topics so those are
the other things that are scripted where
I'm kind of stepping out of my Lane a
little bit basically if I feel like I
want to talk about something because I
think it's important but it's not
something that I feel so knowledgeable
about that I can go off the the cuff
that I will script but again I'm not sum
summarizing other people's stuff I'm
pulling my thoughts my examples and
Consulting with my friends so the
pleasure ISM aspect for me as someone
who doesn't really script I don't really
super have to worry about that
one except for the citation aspect cuz
plagiarism at its core is just taking
somebody's work and words and presenting
it as your own yes even if if you change
some of the order of the wording or some
of the specific individual words if
you're still formatting it the way they
formatted it and saying what they're
saying and you pulled it from them and
you could put them side by side and go
that is pretty much the exact same
sentence that is plagiarism regardless
of whether you cite it or not but
citation is something that I need to be
better about looking at these kind of
woke me up to that because I have a
tendency when I do citations like I'll
look stuff up especially if it's a quote
and every now and then I'll pull a
specific article and in some cases I'm a
little bit saved by the fact that if I'm
showing headlines or talking about
headlines in the news I show you some of
them or if I'm talking about comments
from my comment section I will show them
to you but that only gets me part of the
way there because like if I'm talking
about the media response to something
yeah I'll take a screenshot of a
headline and you'll see where it came
from cool I still should be linking to
that in the description so that you know
I didn't Photoshop it
cuz personally I'm honestly too lazy to
even try and do that but it would be a
valid concern even taking a screenshot
and presenting it that's something but
that's not a proper
citation similarly when pulling quotes
from people often
creators I will often just find a place
that reported on when they said it it
may or may not be the primary place
where they said it like if it was for an
interview or something but I'll often
screenshot that so that I can just drop
in a screenshot and not have to retype
and figure out how to format uh for the
best visual presentation the this quote
cuz I'm not a I'm not a visual designer
like at all there's a reason I pay
somebody else to do my thumbnails a
quick sidebar if you're not following my
thumbnail guy uh Joel on Twitter at this
handle you really should he's really
talented he does original art there as
well and he's also quite funny Joel's
great and thank goodness he swept in to
save me for my own ineptitude on the
thumbnails but something visually that I
can take a shortcut I will partially out
of yes laziness other than the
thumbnails I'm a onep person operation
but in addition to that because it was
stuff that I didn't think required me to
do more than I was doing but the thing
is even if I pull a quote even if I
Source it from somewhere I should still
be saying what that source is if for no
other reason that if the source is
wrong I can point to it and go oh that's
why I made a mistake because I got it
from here and they were wrong now you
can then decide to make your own call as
to whether I should have caught that or
not but if I just pull a quote and it's
wrong and I don't site where I got it
from then it's on
me because I didn't tell you where it
came from and my citation regardless of
whatever research I did or didn't do if
I don't put where I get the information
from then my citation amounts to trust
me
bro and I shouldn't be doing that and I
didn't think of myself as doing that
because I know the back end I have a
bias in terms of bias of knowledge of
how much work I do put into these I know
the research that I do but I have to
show my work and make it clear to you
the research that I
do you may or may not have noticed you
probably didn't that in my most recent
review of Doctor Who that when I put up
um a bit of a clip from an interview
with Russell T Davis and David Tennant I
put a citation of what the show was when
I pulled a quote from Russell T Davis
talking about that he didn't intend to
rcon the Timeless child I put a little
citation at the bottom saying where he
originally said that that actually even
wasn't technically where I got it from
but the place where I got it from cited
where it did come from originally and
that's what I put there I'm going to try
and start doing that going forward
whenever especially if I'm pulling a
quote or I'm pulling a clip because it
didn't honestly occur to me for people
to think that if I say pulled a montage
that somebody else made that they'd
think I actually did it because again I
don't do much fancy stuff and I don't
know if I have specifically done that
but if I have and anyone thought that I
did more work than I did well
that's undue credit to me and not proper
credit to whoever did it and this
doesn't mean that you can't
take stuff from other YouTubers there
are a handful of clips that I've used in
the past and probably will use again
Clips such as if you know it's bad why
are you doing it the fan base
ising
exhausting and I will continue to use
stuff like that but I need to start
citing specifically where it is coming
from and that is something that I should
have been better at long before this I'm
just going to Chu this up to a blind
spot because I didn't approach what I
did through an academic lens like I said
I don't consider myself a video essayist
but even the stuff that I did Heavy
research
on I didn't site as well as I could have
or should have I know I did the research
but if you were to ask me now hey what's
what's the exact Source like can you
give me a link
for your Source on
that I'd have to go find it again cuz I
didn't put it on the record and that's
just bad work on my
part something that I think both Todd in
the shadows and H bomber Guy brought up
which I think is valid is we tend to
think of YouTube as a little bit of the
Wild West like ah there's no
rules well there should
be in many ways there aren't there's
terms of service technically gets
violated frequently and people don't get
punished and people get punished for
violating it when they in fact did not
but
like
honesty
transparency there's no enforcement
mechanism for that stuff here the
dealing of
misinformation basically comes down to
stuff that is like fully completely
debunked and if YouTube allows to stay
up they are potentially going to get in
legal trouble so that's why like they'll
pull vaccine misinformation but YouTube
has neither the time nor the ability to
check everything that was allowed to go
up it's a pretty much open door policy
and we kind of have to do our best for
our own stuff and police each other to a
certain degree which I guess is
ultimately what H bomber guy and Todd
and the Shadows did but as I said they
shouldn't have needed to come in and
sweep in with this overwhelming ing
evidence because people were trying to
bring attention to this and just being
shut down ignored and not listened
to and as I said I think there's
responsibility some for the audience but
a lot for
creators this is a reminder that even if
you don't
do what James Summerton did which is to
flatly steal people's other people's
words and thoughts and ideas and flatly
lie about things even if you don't do
that which I don't again think I ever
have but even if you don't you can still
learn
oh I can
still improve like he fell short in so
many areas that I could be better on am
I as bad as him no but that's not the
Baseline that can't be the metric it
can't be well I'm not doing what he did
okay
that doesn't mean that you're doing
enough so for myself going forward I'm
going to try real hard to be better
about citations both in the body of the
video and if it is appropriate with
links in the description honestly links
in the description is what I am more
likely to forget to do so if I say
something and it's not cited
call me on it
please I'm one person with
ADHD this is this is not something I Am
Naturally inclined to be good at but I'm
going to
try because while I know I am not James
Summerton I want to push myself for just
to be as far away from even being close
to the kind of nonsense he pulled and
the least Le I can do is get better
about the citations and I intend
to so those are my thoughts on all this
and the lessons for us to keep in mind
as viewers especially as creators going
forward so
that we can have a little less of this
maybe in the future potentially at least
that'd be
nice as I said this was not meant to be
even a overview of the stuff that he did
but if you have any thoughts on what I
have
said in specific about what lessons can
be learned drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living and even if you can't help me
out that way there's other stuff that I
do there is links for those things in
the description those are always there
because that's a permanent template so
those don't get forgotten but like share
subscribe also help don't worry about it
what what what I really want you to
remember viewer or Creator or
both you are beautiful you are valid and
you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zuman Lula
goddess Salida Terra the thing that goes
do in the anime Ruth goer the Garian
Oliver B solitary pictures rri Bogden
Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808
Becky Sparks forab likes the poodle
Robin Powell t love Tracy scrapit angry
Casper Dave Hall Roselyn Bennett have
fun tonight and thank you for your Port
I don't know why I decided to do that
this time but I don't know I'm having
[Music]
fun
y